we can't mention
music's healing power in 2020 without
talking about beyonce
a woman who continues to give so much of
herself as an
artist with blackest king black parade
savage remix and her grammy nominations
i'll go on record to say that i think
2020 has been one of her most
influential years yet joining me now to
talk more about her
impact it's et lives denny directo and
tondo glomo
are y'all ready to talk b always
ready let's do it okay
it will only be right to start this
conversation off with the shock waves
that black is king sent around the world
on july 31st
2020 now tondo you were one of the first
people i called after watching this
visual album
i didn't care what time it was in
california i
blew your phone up so as a south african
native i know you have a close
connection to this project
tell us how it was personal for you you
blew
my line for good reason for good reason
okay and this is the thing so as a south
african
seeing all of the artists okay every
name that is listed as a feature
as a producer as a director from people
like
burna boy people like whiz
kid people like busy swahili
in the music video i mean these are
household names where i come from
in nigeria south africa your east
african artists these are artists that
are well respected for their craft
so bee was intentional in the kind of
people that she sought after
and number one knowing that afrobeats
has become a household
thing now exposing all of that and
putting it in the
mainstream i i couldn't stand any harder
i couldn't
i couldn't and she was so dedicated to
sharing you know african art with the
world
i mean she really sat on this project
for a year after
the album which the film was based on
the gift was released we
you know this obviously coincided with
when the lion king dropped we got the
album but then
we had to wait a whole year before we
got black is king and what i appreciated
about it too
was the fact that like not only did she
collaborate with all these amazing
um black and african artists on the
album but she did that even in the
wardrobe too
or the location she shot black is king
which as we know with beyonce
all of that is part of something way
bigger you see when i did that
it did that
right it all lends itself to her visual
storytelling which was so
stunning when watching this film but
also it just gave
visibility to a lot of black creators
i agree with you i agree with you and
there there's a video that i absolutely
love
of steph and aisha curry's daughter
riley
dancing to beyonce's song already right
after black is king was released
and i just had this feeling of wow this
visual album is really affecting young
black kids i think in a way that
we're not even really going to know
until the future right
it's just so cool to see this pod the
positive effect that this film
is having on young black kids that was a
huge standout moment for me
and also the perfect timing of this film
you mentioned denny that this was
something she started working on a while
ago
none of us knew 2020 was gonna be what
it was but
it came out at the perfect time after
the killing the back-to-back killings of
ahmad aubrey brianna taylor and george
floyd
at a time where black people honestly we
needed a reminder
of our value and our beauty and our
power and beyonce was right there to
give it to us
she came through she came through for
young black women she came through
for baby girls who saw themselves as
beautiful brown skinned girl girl
listen she came through it was
definitely an anthem but she also came
through
for black men too i mean there's a
reason why at the end of the film
she dedicates the whole piece to her own
son
sir carter you know because she is um
she's hopeful i think is what her
message was for a world
where black boys and black girls are
safe
and also they're just celebrated yeah
and where they they know their worth i
think that's about everything
yeah so we obviously can't talk about
black
young kids knowing their worth and
growing up in this world knowing their
value
without talking about miss blue ivy who
is one of the inspirations behind
beyonce's work her children drive what
she does
now blue ivy was featured on the song
brown skin girl she was also credited as
a songwriter alongside her famous
parents
and ms blue was given the ashford and
simpson songwriters award at the 2019
bet soul train awards
blue has had a year she has accomplished
multiple things in 2020
how do you feel about blue's
accomplishments guys
i feel like she probably did as much in
2020 as her mama did
you know what i mean yeah not only did
she score that bet soul train award but
she
also became the youngest person ever to
receive a bet award which
you know her grandma miss tina made sure
we all knew
that her little grandbaby was out here
collecting awards
let's not forget blue also was a
narrator
of an iconic um
hair love okay we heard blue's voice in
there
and that came to us by surprise as well
just when you thought she had
songwriter b b t award winning
at just the tender age of eight guys
right it doesn't get any better
blue blue out here trying to save lives
yes
thank you we appreciate it now blue's
trying to save lives and saw her parents
because
in truth a lot of their uh work this
year was
in trying to impact and change
uh and uh touch black culture in the
best and most intentional way possible
from blue giving the brown skinned girls
the audacity to
love themselves and to work work even
harder
her mom queen bee planting seeds back
into the communities of color
through black parade
[Music]
what resonated with me most is the fact
that proceed proceeds to this went to
small and black businesses
outside of the fact that the song itself
was so powerful
so fun so i think one of the things i
love the most about the whole black
parade movement
is the awareness it brought to the
juneteenth holiday
because beyonce because she tied such a
powerful project
and her rollout of this song around june
19th
a number of fans who were unfamiliar
with why that day is worth celebrating
learn that it is the official day
slavery
quote unquote official day slavery ended
in america
and honestly i never thought it would be
at a point where we will be having
conversations about pop culture in
juneteenth at the same time
but only beyonce can do that so
and we're here and look beyonce is no
stranger to pain homage to black culture
in her work and in her art i mean
before black is king before black black
parade we got
homecoming you know and her iconic
coachella performance where she
literally paid homage to hbcus you know
and
but the thing about black parade though
is you know when you listen to the
lyrics of that song you know she's
talking about
people being pressed because um she's
black
but it's also really more than anything
a celebration it's like they're pressed
for a reason
here are all the amazing qualities in
our community you know and of course
this again dropped
not only on juneteenth but also amid the
social
unrest this cultural reckoning that
happened following george floyd's death
so
she knew what she was doing and and for
her i feel like
it's become less and less about
streaming numbers and record sales
for hershey trying to make an impact and
also just like
show up for the black community and
that's why obviously as
tondo mentioned she was donating the
proceeds to the song
to black owned small businesses who were
also maybe suffering a little bit during
this pandemic so
she knew what she was doing and and you
know what not only do we get black
parade this year from beyonce
we also got savage remix let's not
forget the fun that she brought and the
joy she brought into our lives this year
to
hopping on this megan the stallion
collab yeah
you guys i mean obviously this was a
massive moment
for meg this gave her her first number
one single
on the billboard hot 100 not to mention
the fact that it's like
oh and of course the the cultural impact
with the savage remake
dance challenge tondo i know you were
all about this
i listen guys i'm still trying to learn
the savage moves okay
i have practice i have tick-tocked
myself to the ground
trying to learn these moves okay so we
saw
culture just take over i mean these were
the two girls who went and created the
actual
savage challenge okay and we saw
everybody trying to do these exact
things guys i don't know if you can
imagine it but i tried
these exact moves i don't see you do
that girl you know how to dance don't
try to play
you're just like i swear
didn't you do it i added a little single
ladies to it because you know why
beyonce always on b
but um obviously like i mentioned uh
like this was so major for megan because
obviously she is collaborating with the
number one artist in the world beyonce
but they also are both from houston and
we got a chance to sit down with megan
and
listen to her cute reaction to even just
being in the same
orbit as queen bee beyonce is
beyonce is the og like she is
the standard like you want to
be like beyonce you want to grow up and
you want to be be like beyonce you watch
beyonce from when you were a kid to this
point in life like y'all say somebody
that is just so top tier so you just
feel so great to know that you've even
made it to where you can be in the room
with beyonce
like i'm like girls breathing beyonce
look beyonce is now her friend right
look beyonce's impact this year i don't
think it would
be complete without a vogue spread
because why not
it's beyonce right the beautiful mom of
three graced the cover of british vogue
giving us
look after look she's stunned
she's stunned well she's appeared on the
cover before
a vogue a number of times in the past
but i'm curious
for you what made this vogue special
this vogue spread so special
well i have to say i noticed in a couple
of those vogue pictures
a little ivy drip okay and
when i saw that and she had already been
posting about it on her instagram
this is when i had to i knew i had to
get my coins ready
collect all my coins and get ready to
make some purchases because this
ivy park drip two collection came in
such a variety we saw
more colors than we've ever seen we saw
more variety in style than we saw in the
last collection so i know
everybody started waiting in those lines
after this uh
vogue vote spread i was one of them you
guys i got
my hands on some ivy park drip too
i didn't get it today didn't he
i should have but it was i i have ptsd i
think because it was like
uh trying to get a concert ticket even
though there's no live shows this year
it was like that trying to get some ivy
park i'm just happy it worked out for me
but yeah no the pieces are fire
there's one point i want to bring up as
well because there was some history made
behind this british
vote cover i want to shout out 21 year
old north carolina native kennedy carter
she was the youngest photographer for
the cover for british vogue and she shot
beyonce this was a dream come true for
her this was an opportunity she didn't
even necessarily
expect but beyonce requested a woman of
color for the shoot
and together with vogue's editor they
came across kennedy and now look she has
beyonce on her portfolio so i'm sure
she would have no problem getting work
in the future
look i i've said this before beyonce's
not just a star she's a whole galaxy let
other stars shine bright next to her
okay so that's what she was doing there
and
by the way that british vogue spread we
got a little hint of what we can expect
from beyonce
in 2021 and sadly it doesn't sound like
any new music she said
she's gonna take some time to step away
and focus on what brings her joy so i
guess we gotta let her do it
we gotta give it to her she does she's
been out since she was what 15.
and then recently she's been putting out
back-to-back projects i think she should
take some time to focus on her kids and
her man
why not again look you're mad about that
right
a little bit we're okay with it
thankfully hopefully we can expect
beyonce
at the grammys next year though because
the girl is collecting some hardware i'm
predicting that right now
no i i think so too she is the most
nominated artist at
the 2021 grammy awards ceremony with
nine nominations
and get this guy she didn't even put out
an album that's beyonce pulling a
beyonce okay
that's that's what she does but she also
continues
right she also continues her reign as
the most nominated female artist in
grammy history with
79 career nominations so
i know she's taking a break which she
deserves but i have a feeling that 2021
is still going to be impactful for b
absolutely
well in the meantime as we look back on
the year that was 2020 you know it
really was the year
for all of us to post up on our couch
and watch some tv
up next and look at the shows that we
were obsessed with this past year
you